so our company
um obviously we're in Las Vegas based we
do a lot of autographed signings with a
lot of the golden Knight players and we
wanted to play homage to the golden
knights jerseys the new retro
glow-in-the-darks so we came up with a
great idea to be able to have the
players sign all the products but glow
in the dark pens I love that yeah so you
can see the autographs in the daytime or
when the the lights are out just like
you see here and you'll get the
glow-in-the-dark effect so you can see
both angles of it this is really cool
and I don't think I've ever seen this
done before this is a really unique idea
did you just come up with it as you were
thinking about something different to do
and try out yeah actually I was at the
first reverse retro game for the golden
knights the players are coming out the
tunnel during uh pregame and the light
bulb just went off like oh my goodness
uh I have to capitalize on this and get
the fans you know product that they're
not going to be able to get any other
place so conceive the idea literally
sitting in my seat in the 100 level of
T-Mobile Arena and here we are today
that is really cool and in addition to
jerseys you have a few other things as
well right uh yeah so we can see the
whole line this one right here for
example is pretty cool we have these are
limited edition out of 10. they're
signed by the the players that we signed
up for the signings were Riley Smith
Logan Thompson Alec Martinez Chandler
Stevenson and Zach White Cloud how was
that yeah so we did a whole line with
just with all the different products we
have jerseys we did pucks right here we
did the reverse retro pucks this right
here is a Logan Thompson Puck that
yes I know I'm like I need to see this
this is awesome we have hooks we got
jerseys we have right here Chandler
Stevenson who just got named an All-Star
uh for the NHL uh yesterday that's going
to be a hot commodity this one's a hot
one it's already going today great
um we did photos right here we did 11 by
14 photos from that first game the one
that I was just telling you about I was
in
so when you turn the lights out
um the signatures do glow so it's pretty
cool how cool it's like almost having
two different photos in one and really
quick please we're going through this I
know people are going to want to get
their hands on this where can they get
this stuff uh you can go onto our
website in scriptograps.com we've sold
over half the inventory we have maybe a
hundred items left between all five
players so the stuff's going off the
shelves uh Logan Thompson being the hot
guy right now with the golden knights
his product is just
it's getting harder and harder to get
and there's so much demand coming from
so if you're big Logan Thompson fan
that's the way to go and then we also
have this awesome photo I'll show you
right here yeah look at this
oh gosh this is so cool Tyler you really
came up with something unique and
creative people are going to love this
stuff they already are because you're
running out of it so it's going thank
you for being here and congratulations
this is such a great idea I really love
it all I can't wait to play under that
blue light and see what surprises are
gonna come out so thank you for being
here thank you so much and Mercedes I
will send it over to you